is due to the the strong support we gave
to households so demand has been strong
and households have shifted their their
you know their demand they're buying
things uh instead of buying services and
things go through ports they have to be
built and that is causing the
bottlenecks in the supply chain
wow
amazing isn't it joining me now is ohio
congressman jim jordan author of the new
book do what you said you would do also
with me as arizona congressman andy
biggs uh congressman jordan let me let
me start with you that kind of an excuse
it's as though like oh well americans
never ordered things before it's
americans fault we want items now and so
that's creating a problem it's as though
with everything we've heard there's this
dance to make it seem as though
we're the ones at fault or that it
really isn't happening at all what's
your take on this
everything costs more is my take on the
american people understand it you want
to buy a home it costs more you want to
rent an apartment it costs more to put
food on the table it costs more to put
gas in your car it costs more to buy a
thanksgiving turkey or christmas
presents it all costs more and what is
joe biden doing hanging out on nantucket
at a billionaire's house eating lobster
i mean the american people get how bad
this administration is and to have joe
biden just a few weeks ago say something
as dumb as he did where he said oh if we
spend two trillion dollars more it will
help inflation there's not a same person
on the planet who believes that this
bill if it does pass here in the senate
let's hope it doesn't it's only going to
exacerbate the 31-year high inflation
rate we're currently experiencing so the
american people get it and that's why 71
percent of the country think we're on
the wrong track well and this is why of
course we can't really expect anything
to get corrected or to change because
they think everything's fine as a matter
of fact speaking of nantucket let's
listen to jen saki who had a few things
to say about that
what message does it send to the middle
class americans president biden says
that he's trying to help that president
is going to take a few days off at a
billionaire's compound in nantucket this
is a time to put politics aside
spend time with your loved ones and talk
about what you're grateful for the
american people can be assured that he
will continue to press to lower their
costs and ensure they have more
breathing room
well congressman biggs it really comes
down to once again a lack of empathy all
of this is a lack of a connection by the
people running this country and
effectively than the free world because
they just can't relate to other people
yeah tammy that's exactly right i mean
he's going to be eating lobster and and
living it up high in the hog the rest of
us we're going to be paying more for
everything like jim just said and
they're going to continue to enforce
these policies that are going to cause
inflation to keep growing i mean
everything from a screwed up supply
chain to they've killed the energy
sector so everything's going to keep
going up and you know what there's a
common denominator to all this and it's
joe biden and he's the guy that's going
to be living it up like he's some kind
of king or monarch while the rest of the
serfs and peasants are going to enjoy
thanksgiving and they don't even want us
to have a turkey and they want us to
send guests home that's how out of touch
they are
you know i think part of this of course
is that they they just lie about what's
going on and on the other hand they are
living lives that are completely unlike
the lives of ever every other american
but when we think about the lying aspect
i want to bring something else in in the
midst of all of this when it comes to
biden
but this issue of what now is breaking
news
about the fact that apparently 82 000
people who came in from afghanistan
were not at all vetted i mean this is is
being exposed this is uh the so i guess
the washington examiner almost none of
the 82 000 people gentlemen who are
airlifted from kabul specifically in
august were vetted 82 000 they were
admitted to the united states this is
now according to a congressional memo
the administration also brought into the
u.s tens of thousands of afghans who are
not qualified on any single level
regarding why they should be here this
is a large majority of people about 75
percent they were not american citizens
they were not green card holders they
were not afghan special immigrant visa
holders but they were effectively
strangers to us
and now we're finding congressman jordan
that there were virtually no personal
interviews done of these people
what can happen at this point what are
you going to do
to hold this administration accountable
with what's going to happen here
yeah a couple things timmy first of all
we find out about this this story breaks
on you know wednesday night before
thanksgiving of course go figure but we
actually knew about this andy and i knew
about this several months ago and raised
this issue when we had secretary mayorka
secretary blinken
in a briefing for members of the
judiciary committee they in essence told
us what you just described that there
was no real vetting of these individuals
and in fact we knew this was the case
there was no way they could do what was
the debacle of the afghan exit that that
biden presided over there's no way they
could properly vet people so we knew
this happened months ago we got the
briefing from secretary blinken and my
orcas they as much as told us that um
we'll continue to try to hold their feet
to the fire and see what what we can do
going forward but this was kind of what
was expected from this administration
that has screwed up everything they have
touched yeah congressman biggs i mean
when we're looking at it is literally
congressman jordan that this this this
issue that nothing has gone right i mean
even a broken clock is right twice a day
here you've got to work hard to have
nothing work i mean this is now we're
dealing with terrorist issues right
we're dealing with uh we've already had
rapes and assaults on our our military
bases against our troops congressman
biggs there's there's got to be this is
clearly a national security threat at
this point what are our options when we
find out something like this has
happened
well i think i think we have to take it
seriously and i think my opinion is we
need to uh uh get
my orcis needs to be replaced he needs
to be be fired and actually so does joe
biden yeah but i mean tammy
we we're up in arms over over the
afghanis because he they let in 86 000
totally unvetted but don't forget that
they that may orcas has let in about 400
getaways across the southern border
great point sir great point congressman
thank you very much for being here just
so much going on and happy thanksgiving
to you gentlemen i appreciate it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else